c'est une ancienne camarade d'école qui
doit l'interviewer sur le tapis rouge
drôle de coïncidence elle va s'en vanter
mais lui se souvient des moqueries
qu'elle lui a dressait plus jeune
attention au moment de jet
er
[Musique]
un homme libéré
mais depuis tout petit depuis tout petit
je le vois voilà il fait chaud
ma mère a honte de moi mais mais
vraiment c'est pas j'ai une passion pour
ça
parce que je suis pas aussi bien coller
toi je pense
[Applaudissements]
la bonne réaction face au racisme c'est
l'universalité c'est-à-dire ce
considérer comme être humain et non pas
comme blanc noir arabe que sais-je le
problème c'est que c'est universalisme
c'est humanisme pour dire le mot
aujourd'hui il est quand même très très
fragilisé et donc raison de plus pour
pour le défendre un attendu entre le
maire de Nice Christian Estrosi et le
cirque Zavatta le cirque se trouve ces
véhicules et une cinquantaine d'animaux
sauvages se sont installés le thon est
encore monté cet après-midi aux abords
du cirque Zavatta fraîchement installé à
l'ouest de Nice essayez de m'empêcher de
rentrer sur mon terrain tout commence
lundi dernier le cirque Zavatta
anciennement Muller s'installent sans
autorisation sur ce terrain de la ville
de Nice déclenchant les foudres du maire
de la ville
et soyez gentils les uns avec les autres
oui merci
[Musique]
de leur côté les responsables du cirque
expliquent être entrées sur ce terrain
pour susciter une réaction
car cette année leur demande répétée
d'installation auprès de la Ville de
Nice serait resté lettres morte en cause
une voie publiée au Journal officiel en
2022 qui prévoit de bannir la détention
d'animaux non domestiques des spectacles
itinérants à compter de décembre 2028
mais certaines municipalités anticiper
la loi selon eux quand on a commencé les
visions il y avait comme une espèce
d'odeur de gaufres ou de crêpes qui se
passait on est où ça sent bon et en fait
c'est dans un plateau à côté qui sans
doute faisait de la cuisine puisque tous
les plateaux de télévision sont voisins
on sait même pas d'ailleurs quelle est
les maisons qui sont sinon je vous jure
que je vous le dirai mais ça sentait bon
tout à l'heure les vidéos de bébés qui
tombent dans le sud pour la toute
première fois font des millions de vues
et comme c'est trop chou et ben on en
profite
[Musique]
[Rires]
là maintenant je pense qu'on est passé à
la cuisson de la friture c'est à dire
que on va rentrer on est d'accord ça
fait un peu on va sentir le graillon
vous êtes d'accord Sandra ça donc comme
ça pue je crois maintenant connaître
l'émission qui se passe à côté mais on
va rester cool
et du beurre en 20 ans la France a
doublé ses importations alimentaires et
notre souveraineté c'est rode un peu
plus chaque année
viande volaille fruits et légumes la
production française est inférieure à
nos besoins
et un nouveau secteur risque bientôt
d'être déficitaire le lait ça c'est un
vrai trésor parce que ça veut dire en
fait qu'on est en train de pouvoir
sauver cette race de vaches qui est
adaptée à 1000 mètres d'altitude dans le
Vercors et venez je vais vous montrer
parce qu'avec Pauline il y a un vrai je
me suis pris un petit coup de queue
en direct comme ça devant tout le monde
c'est gênant donc là regardez ça c'est
très important
hagribashing un mot récent qui désigne
les critiques récurrentes envers
l'agriculture près de la moitié des
Français considèrent les agriculteurs
comme des pollueurs
usage de pesticides ou bien naître
animal des débats légitimes mais dans
certains cas la violence des accusations
peut aussi les contraindre à arrêter
leur métier
[Musique]
comme un chat
c'est difficile de se rendre compte pour
le grand public en fait oui
il se demande comment peut être éleveur
et puis comment on peut les emmener à
l'abattoir quand même
sont très têtus
comme une femme
ce qui est bien quand on parle français
c'est que quand on est dans un pays
étranger et bah du coup vous pouvez
grave insulter les gens ils vont rien
comprendre par
espèce de Salt taxi de merde et ben
voilà il a rien compris quoi
vous avez dit que votre porte-bonheur
c'est votre chéri il l'a aussi votre
chéri non non il est pas là ah bon
d'accord il y a que votre frère et votre
sœur
on m'a dit le 62 Jérémy c'est son chéri
oh la menteuse il est où le 62 il est où
le 62 il est où c'est votre chéri ou pas
je viens d'apprendre que je ne l'étais
plus apparemment
[Applaudissements]